每个人面对行情按下进场确认按钮前,都要严肃地问问自己,你有清晰的交易规则吗?如果没有,接近100%的可能,你将成为失败者。所以,建立你的交易规则是你目前的第一要务。听话照做,我没什么多余的漂亮语言可以给你解释的。不要浪费自己的时间在一个不可能成功的错误道路上。
理查德D唐奇安可能算是近代趋势跟踪之父
他之所以成名
可能与他能从失败中快速学习与反思并且无私分享有关
今天分享他的这个20个交易指南
希望各位能从中有所收获
理查德D唐奇安最初在1934年编撰了这些20个交易指南
以帮助股票市场交易者
他在1966年再次发现了这些规则的完整副本
并且发现他们中的大多数同样适用于商品以及股票
而且这20条规则都保持了他们的实用性和有效性
到了1978年
这些规则依然合理
唐齐安是华尔街尤其是在商品领域最受尊敬的技术分析师之一
他在1930年开始了他的职业生涯
并表示当他阅读了埃德温·勒菲福
关于杰西·利弗莫尔的虚构传记
股票作手回忆录时
他对市场产生了浓厚的兴趣
他对技术分析的兴趣
源于在1929年的股市崩盘后遭受了一些损失
这导致他发现
只有图表分析师能够理解市场并赚取利润
理查德·唐企安在25岁时
即1930年撰写了他的第一份市场通讯
而后来的施森公司现在的趋势定时商品通讯
起源于1960年
当时唐齐安加入了海登私通公司
这些通讯为无数商品交易者提供了入门教程二是交易指南是对这些信件的很好补充很可能在接下来的44年里同样会存续并证明其有效性
一般指南
以谨慎对待广泛的公众意见
即使正确
它通常也会延迟市场的变动
二
在市场呈现沉闷和不活跃的时期
观察并准备跟随那些
伴随着交易量增加的市场走向
三 限制亏损 持续获利 无视其他所有规则
四 当市场位置不确定时 适量投资是明智的
明确的市场动向经常会发出信号
足以使得交易充满趣味 专注于这些动向
并排除其他可能导致不盈利的来回震荡
五 不要在连续三天内的市场移动方向后经常
等待一天的反转
六明智地使用止损单对盈利交易很有帮助
止损单可以用来保护利润
限制亏损
以及在某些形态下建仓
如三角形焦点
如果与图表形态恰当关联
止损单可能更有价值且风险较小
七在可能上涨和下跌相等
或上涨更大的市场中
出于百分比的原因
应在上涨时持有更重的仓位
从50跌至25的情况只能获得50%的利润
而从25上升至50则能获得100%的利润
8件仓时可以接受限价单
平仓时使用试价单
9买入表现强劲
背景强大的商品
卖出表现弱的商品
但需符合所有其他规则
10铁路
现在的交通指数
领先或强烈参与的市场动向
通常比铁路落后的动向更值得跟随
十一研究公司的资本化
某一问题的活跃程度
一个变化因素
以及该问题是像康涅迪格埃迪生
或埃克森这样的迟钝货车
还是像泰勒迪恩
纽约证券交易所
或国际度假村美国这样的精力充沛波动性强的赛马与研究统计报告同等重要波动性股票是1978年两个在1934年提到的问题的当代对应
分别是当时在场外市场的美国旅业公司
和现在属于田纳科的G.I.凯斯托利基公司
技术指南
这些技术指南同样适用于主要和次要心态
一依次走势之后的横盘整理
通常预示着几乎与原始移动相等幅度的另一次移动
通常
当第二次从横盘区域移动结束后
可以预期一个接近横盘范围的反向移动
二
遇到移动的逆转或阻力可能发生在
A
商品在过去较长时间内在狭窄范围内波动的水平上
或
B
接近之前的高点或低点
三
当接近趋势线时
尤其是在中等或低交易量的情况下
要注意良好的买入或卖出机会
确保这样的线没有被频繁靠近或触及参见第四条
似观察沿着或反复触碰次咬或主要趋势线的情况
并准备看到这些趋势线被突破
五打破次咬趋势线与主要趋势相反
提供了最重要的建仓信号
可以在此类地点通过止损单件仓或反向操作
这可能是所有技术指南中最重要的
六 无论斜律如何
三角形可能意味着积累或分配
这取决于其他因素
尽管三角形通常在平坦的一侧被突破
七 注意成交量高潮
特别是在长期移动之后
八 不要指望跳空被填补
除非你能区分突破性跳空
普通跳空和耗尽跳空
久在走势中
在任何一天的反转之后的第二天早晨
无论反转多微小
尤其是如果成交量在反转时下降
就按走势方向增加或建立头寸
这一被证明是非常有价值的指导经过40多年的经验积累后唐奇安认为这些1934年的指南中对商品交易者最有用的是
一般指南下的第三条
和技术指南下的第四、五和九条
1978年12月的
Comets黄金期货图表
有助于进一步说明技术指南第五条
唐奇安将逆趋势定义为
至少持续4天的一系列动作
捡黄金图表中的插图
该图展示了这种模式
交易者可以在价格穿过第四天的极端时
或者在整个走势的极端处设置止损单来建立头寸
在底部日的最低点下方或顶部日的最高点上方设置止损单
在12月的黄金图表上
标示了几个成功的四天逆趋势案例
请注意这个警告
如果逆趋势很陡峭
价格通常需要超过4天的修正
此外
即使在现有趋势方向出现陡峭的4天逆趋势
这也可能是一个警告
表明价格变动的速度可能正在放缓
较长的逆趋势序列也能提供良好的市场信号
例如
1月末到2月初的修正
给出了一个很好的买入信号
当你关注较长的逆趋势或整理时
要注意修正的速度不如主要移动的前一阶段快
此外
要注意修正时的低层交量和突破时的高层交量
及快速势头
这些线索增强的主要趋势仍然占主导地位的可能性
所有这些指南都作为一般的交易工具
它们的成功应用需要一些个人解释
例如
在第五条中
你必须知道主要趋势才能使用次要逆趋势
有时那个主要移动可能不明确或受到观点的影响
当这些指南与其他基本技术工具结合使用时
可以提供最大的帮助
顺应趋势交易
有纪律的计划
多样化
短期内削减亏损
长期保持盈利
使用足够的资本和保持耐心